beaucoup de réactions évidemment depuis
hier soir des différentes chancelleries
ça bouge du côté forcément des des
ambassades l'autriche à l'instant fait
savoir qu'elle convoque l'ambassadeur
russe ce qu'a fait déjà le royaume uni
un peu plus tôt boris johnson qui
s'expriment et qui confirmait la volonté
du royaume uni et dans sanctionné de
frapper fort le portefeuille des russes
le président ukrainien avait dit ce
matin envisager la rupture de ses
relations diplomatiques avec la russie
l'a lui même rappelé son ambassadeur à
amour à moscou at on est on arrivé à un
point de non retour nous posions la
question un peu plus tôt à notre invité
david cadier professeur de politique
européenne à l'université de groningen
spécialiste de la russie et de l'europe
centrale écoutez le
après la décision hier de moscou de
reconnaître l'indépendance des entités
séparatistes de donetsk est lougansk
nous avons fait un malheureusement un
pas de plus vers un risque de conflit
ouvert d'un risque de conflit armé et
donc il s'agit tout à la fois maintenant
de signal est inexact habilités de cette
décision russe mais également de faire
pression pour éviter le pire en quelque
sorte il s'était montré ouvert ces
dernières heures toujours à la à la
diplomatie il le redit encore
aujourd'hui tout en expliquant qu'il ne
croit pas en l'invasion de l'ukraine
dans son ensemble à l'arrivée de troupes
russes de soldat russe à kiev là aussi
il est dans une guerre de communication
toujours
c'est à dire que c'est vraiment la
question la lumière poutine comme à son
habitude on bon judoka cherchent à
déstabiliser l'adversaire et donc il
entretient le flou sur les intentions de
la russie lorsqu'on parle du dombass il
faut se comprendre qu'on parle une
région qui comprend deux entités
administratives de donetsk est lougansk
qui sont pour l'instant coupée en deux
avec d'un côté des séparatistes pro
russes et de l'autre côté l'armée
ukrainienne vladimir poutine quand il a
dit reconnaître ces entités on n'est pas
sûr de quelle entité il parle va-t-il
chercher à reprendre des bouts de
territoire qui sont actuellement
contrôlées par les ukrainiens cela
amènerait à une guerre ouverte au
président céline ce qui semble espérer
que vladimir poutine s'arrêtera à la
ligne de contact
qui sépare aujourd'hui le côté ukrainien
le côté séparatiste pro russe mais
encore une fois nous ne sommes pas sûrs
et le vrai dilemme pour les occidentaux
c'est précisément d'éviter le pire et de
contraintes de l'avenir poutine à ne pas
dépasser cette ligne de contact